hey welcome back to another episode of
visual effects Artistry act you know
long before Disney thought about doing
The Lion King remake they needed to
First make that digital Studio happen
and there's a movie they made to launch
all of it
no oh do you think that's cool well
check this out I have a films about this
invisible guy and I have to say the end
of this film has some of the most
mind-blowing CGI I have seen for a movie
of this era
like that foot looks photo real this is
way better the effects than the dessert
we'd get a little nutty about the ending
so in the year 2000 Disney made this
movie called dinosaur which is basically
the precursor to everything modern with
Disney's digital Studios so they could
do CG characters they could do all this
compositing they needed a team of
animators so they could move into the
future so that they can one day make
Moana
not just that but like all the
live-action Disney's their technological
Roots point to Dinosaur so this is their
pilot piece for the next 20 years of
films exactly
here's the thing the CT does look pretty
dated in this movie there's a lot of
really impressive stuff in it so get
going you'll be like oh nice game
cinematic sometimes just just for
reference first attempt at making a
photo real main character out of CGI
just happened in 1999. Jar Jar Binks Jar
Jar Binks was actually the first attempt
at a photo reel non-cartoon CGI
character so this came out in 2000 2000
so just two years before Gollum
all right
no oh
boom taken down that's not a T-Rex
that's a dinosaur Carnotaurus it really
carnotauradon Sam knows he's got a
five-year-old boy yeah Carnotaurus is
the cool one by the way it's like what
else makes a T-Rex cooler yeah two
little horns
so it's yours the dinosaurs uh asteroid
it's the Earth and then these are the
survivors it's it's the road so
dinosaurs Disney's take on the road with
Dinosaurs yeah
I find myself really impressed by the
hair going on here what year did
Monsters Inc come out this came out a
year before Monsters Inc no kidding
because Monsters Inc is like the big
example of like early great hair
simulations but I'm just seeing a ton of
that here and it looks pretty dang good
so they built their own hair system for
this it took the guy six months just to
make it and then like another six months
to like actually get it running I
believe I think it's called pleo playo
and yeah it basically every lemur has
about the amount of hairs that are on a
human head I think it's about two
million hairs each hair had a serial
number so if you wanted to you could
address them individually like one into
color damn wow comb them you could
sculpt them you could place them they
had ways you could like match them for
like having like wet hair basically they
discover that wet hair clumps together
at points they would go and like they'd
pick their pet cats and they'd get them
wet oh I'm sure they love that yeah but
there's still like some issues you can
see with like old hair rendering for
example as you get deeper into hair it
blocks more and more light as we call it
ambient occlusion dude I was just about
to say it I was like on the tip of my
tongue I'm like also the one big thing
that makes this look really flat is no
ambient occlusion anywhere yep yep you
know ambient inclusion it is basically
the shadow that forms as two objects
approach contact with each other
therefore blocking out the light it's
literally just darkness calculated by
how close two surfaces are yes you can
see it if you look in the corner of a
room it's dark in that corner because
that's where the contact surfaces are
closest look at the light value of the
very bottom of his chin right where the
shadow begins and then you go all the
way down to the crease of his neck right
there and it's uniform in reality you
would see a slight shading difference
along that crevice
all right check out this grass
wow
these dinosaurs compd on this grass they
were like how do we do this grass and
these dinosaurs in it they're like oh we
invented fur let's just do it for the
grass also oh damn first M wait but Sam
it's the Earth's hair this shot comp
nightmare wow
is that a cop nightmare wait that's this
is real grass this is now a real place
that's real grass it's real grass yeah
oh you're right I see the compositing
wow that's uh is that a composite that's
a tall order
embossing nightmare because you have to
cut out every blade of grass and somehow
layer it they don't have like deep
compositing at this time there's no way
to be like oh this pixel the models
behind this pixel of the grass
somebody's got to go in by hand and be
like okay reveal these parts and don't
reveal these parts oh Jesus wow or
that's what you would think turns out
there's a trick it turns out they're
actually really smart they didn't just
shoot a whole CT dinosaur movie and then
have no idea how to composite grass
every one of these shots is planned and
fully animated before they film the
movie because they go out to locations
we're going to shoot here they take
measurements they'd come back they'd
rebuild the entire scene to those
specifications animate it there once
they had that they went back onto set
and then the camera guys to basically
just watch the CG animation and pretend
to shoot the CG animation so you're
locked into the camera work now but
you're also locked into the animation so
I will if we're just locked into the
animation let's go out there with not a
green screen not a blue screen but a red
screen and if the dinosaur is going to
be here in front of the grass plop that
red screen down in the grass and then
move along that's actually really clever
I'm using red is the opposite of green
so it gives you like the easiest sort of
green screen ability dude that's sweet
that's super cool so normally you put a
green screen behind a person because
you're going to take that person and put
them into a CG scene but now what
they're doing is the exact opposite
they're putting a red screen behind
their environment and turning their
environment into this CG location
basically so like filming that plate
there like all right now we're rolling
someone puts the the big red card down
then forward and forward maybe rolling
for like you know 10 seconds per hold
and then you have now a 10 second clip
of all these different layers that you
can stack up yep and the CG is based on
them going to the locations where
they're eventually going to get the
photographic elements so it's all real
measurements actually lined up with
where things are so that they can then
go back and actually get this exact shot
wow
all right
wait
up wait what the heck that's real water
right there but wait how do they do that
if it's a CG animal oh I know what they
did they had a green foot
I don't think it's a green foot but they
had an actual like dinosaur leg made
specifically that matched the CG
dinosaur leg to do that shot and then
they had to composite out the real I was
about to say it looked like there was
definitely something real there that the
water was interacting with the shadow on
the water on the left side there it's
like that's that's a real shadow on the
water that's not just darkening but the
foam matched between it so it wasn't
like a comp shot either another really
cool thing is they they invented their
own muscle system you know once again
this stuff didn't exist you're seeing it
all be invented and they made a movie
about dinosaurs how they invented it
and they had you know muscles basically
forms or just you know 3D shapes that
you know attach that in squash and
squish and then to do the skin all they
had to do is a vertex in the skin would
just find the nearest vertex of muscle
and it would just stick to it Ah that's
all they did basically it's been 23 plus
years since that movie was made and now
we have prehistoric Planet 1 and season
two yep
oh the first dude first gotten so much
better man this is like real the great
grandchild of dinosaur the hero of all
these shots is just the extremely
detailed model and texture work on each
of these Dinosaurs most of the
environments I'm pretty sure were
practically filmed and it's all just
like going through Great Lengths trying
to match the CG to those environments
you know what's weird I can still see
the Legacy inside of this I can see the
shots of dinosaur dinosaur gets cartoony
and Goofy sometimes but there's a lot of
shots and dinosaurs that like if you
squint kind of look the same as these
shots he's going really hard you have to
like you have to really squint I but I
could see that I could see it now wait I
can't tell her we watching dinosaurs
yeah you know what it looks more like to
me though
today's sponsor expressvpn if you're not
using a VPN you're not internet
incorrectly and here's why it gives you
access to content that isn't available
in your country or region specifically I
use this to access all my favorite
sports teams
you can't do that you can't tell a free
and open Internet that you're accessing
the free and open internet from a place
that you're not in actually you can
because it's free and open huh
they got me they got them hooks in deep
at least expressvpn literally it makes
it possible for me they're playing their
games and guess what I'm just playing
them right back and finally expressvpn
gives your data an additional layer of
encryption while it's out on the open
Internet that gives you security and
makes you basically invisible to
everybody else out there kind of like
Kevin Bacon and Hollow Man guys I'm
disappearing if you want to get a
expressvpn for yourself go to
expressvpn.com corridorcrew and if you
sign up for a year you can get three
months free that's exp r e s s vpn.com
or just click the link in the
description below
it's perfect that you brought up skin
muscles all that stuff because a year
before this another film attempted
muscle simulations and you know what I'm
just gonna say that it's not even the
best part of it let's let's just take a
look
wait this is the hollow man this is the
hollow man
[Laughter]
oh oh oh oh
okay that's cool there's layers
they got layers Sam oh yeah
[Music]
dude
wow that's the motion tracking on this
is motion tracking is insanity it's not
just motion tracking it's like bone
tracking and muscle tracking yeah
everything like they're twitching on top
of the bone like you're right and the
craziest thing is that in all those
shots of him transforming he's actually
there Kevin Bacon's actually there
performing that wow look the skin
sliding as they rotate the arms see how
the skin is actually moving at a
different speed and twisting at a
different rate than all the inner
muscles there it's amazing it's not
great I guess nailing the biology was
really important here
but they
name it's a lot wetter looking which I
can appreciate yeah
and that is also a CG bed top oh you're
right these days people just assume that
if you have green in the shot it becomes
invisible you still have to actually
make sure that there's something there
behind it after the fact wait this came
out before dinosaur actually I think
this came out the same year as dinosaur
you'll see you'll see how incredibly
good this next part looks
wait wait
oh yeah wow look at that wait oh oh and
the blood showed up on her forehead this
is really cool
this is way better VFX than the dessert
like that foot looks photo real look how
freaking good that is the water splash
what like she was interacting with
someone someone was throwing her around
yeah but like the wetness the that is
like the juiciest wetness I've seen in
CGI this looks incredible like I don't
know if this would look any different if
he did this now is he painted green here
too and they're just taking some of that
so in all those shots he's actually
there Kevin Bacon's actually there
performing that wow yeah that stuff okay
well do you see the world contacts yeah
so you can see the wetsuit or the rash
guard shirt he's wearing but they're
able to extract all of the The rain
that's going between him and the camera
oh yeah that's right it works as a Luma
mask for the rain yeah he's basically
acting as effectively a green screen for
the rain
yeah he's the red screen for the rain so
he has to track this by hand to a real
person doing all these actions yeah but
then he's in front of her like right
before he throws her into the wall like
he's in front of her and you can see
through him to see her so people have to
be like painting in all these pieces and
everything dude I love when his foot is
on her throat yeah I mean like from a
visual effects standpoint I'm just
saying
um
like you could easily like fake that
like oh there's someone on my neck but
like she's actually being held down and
she's gripping an actual foot like look
at the ambient occlusion on the bottom
of her chin something's there yeah
something is there it's probably what
ambient inclusion is a little too dark
here because it's real it was National
ambient occlusion from an invisible
waterfoot it would be much brighter yeah
but since a real foot was used it's very
dark it's so rare that you see something
that holds up over two decades later I
thought dinosaur was impressive
Sony's just being like catch up Disney
yeah all this talk of water is getting
me pretty excited for a little project
I'm cooking up called Avatar three
so James Cameron took about 10 years to
figure out how to do motion capture
underwater and I was messing around with
my phone I think I got it figured out in
a day or two
so you're going to want to check this
out it's coming out this week here on
Corridor crew stay subscribed
who did I call my name yeah I called you
up your name is
I watched it to me back in the day and
then Eddie Murphy made like four more
clone movies after this what I meant to
see was
your lip how do you think they did that
that's gonna be makeup for a minute oh
yeah back in the day like you have a lot
of like image warping tools you know
it's like you're coming hot off like the
morph Trends from like the early 90s
yeah so I mean uh I think Rick Baker is
his name yeah like a practical effects
here Rick Baker did a ton of practical
effects yeah so he he did all of the
work for this movie and made a whole
bunch of different like prosthetic
costumes that he can get in obviously
the full like fat suit but all of the
different like face fat suits but
there's a shot here when he's in the car
that wow there's like Transitions and
stuff and Rhythm and Hughes handled all
like the transitionary aspects of this
so they would have like fully prosthetic
models for each of the sort of like hero
poses hero looks and then Rhythm and
Hughes would go in and do like digital
transitions between stuff they're doing
liquify warping to the image I think
it's like yeah 50 50.
so I'm watching through this and I'm
like what why does this look off to me
and I realized I'm pretty sure he's on a
blue screen yeah he's gotta he's
completely separate from the background
in all of these shots don't forget
that's also him when it's his dad and
his mom that's him too yeah right right
so they're doing like classic morphs
here to go between different
performances that he's doing but you can
really see when he slaps his hand like
disappears and his head gets all like
thin and That's a classic artifact from
motion blur on a green screen or blue
screen yeah when you have blurred motion
and you're trying to key that out you're
only left with a little bit that's not
blurred out and so you end up with like
skinny head or no hand yeah you can
definitely tell they're struggling with
the King a little bit here and like the
VFX team's doing their best probably to
make up for something that was shot and
set not particularly well yeah yeah but
then granted it's also 96 so it's like
putting motion blur back onto footage is
not necessarily a thing just yet yeah
one
one morphing like one head whilst on top
of another body but like also like
having parts of the skin like move and
animate as like a separate like visual
element that looks like a very difficult
shot right here there's so much like
manipulation in the image happening
there's somebody's like using mesh warp
and liquify and animating all that going
back and seeing all these like older
movies from the 90s and early 2000s
where CG was still in more or less it's
like toddler infancy stage yeah but you
still have all these move these that
look incredible and that's mostly due to
the incredible compositing yeah I know
compositors 20 years ago we're just like
waiting for everyone else to catch up to
their level that's what it feels like
it's always interesting watching these
older films because their visual effects
need to hold up for more than just a
year the movie comes out in a way these
visual effects do hold up because
they're not being made for the sake of
doing the visual effects the movie is
being made with a concept in mind and
they're just using whatever tools they
have at the time to deliver that Concept
in a way that still delivers the concept
right so regardless of however much
tools evolve in the future they were
just delivering a concept and that
concept is still in existence how it
should be hit me with the best VFX shot
you've seen in a place where you didn't
expect to see it and a shot came up and
you're like wow somebody went really
hard on that
that'd be a good recommendation